so you found
my secret huh
[Music]
why why do you want to know my secret
yeah well you're right triple phobia
why does this ungodly thing exist i i've
seen it all
pimple popping toenails losing
but ain't nothing come even close to
triple
[ __ ]
[Music]
phobia
all right here we go
in the course of half a billion years of
evolution a suriname
toad has eggs that hatch in pockets on
her back
ah skin care as it were
[Music]
oh i don't know leaving her
just kill us out this is why we invented
flame throwers
flame away boys it was me it was a
pokemon
battle me versus surinam toad
i'd be dead i'd just accept my fate and
die
die fast oh
why what is with holes and why am i so
scared of them
except a certain type of them now these
look like butt holes that
multiplied and i can respect that so i
don't have a problem with this the
butthole thing
what is this
what the [ __ ] is that i don't know what
it is i don't care if it lives
but it needs to [ __ ] die i hate holes
i just hate holes
i do what can i say ah god
[Music]
you're swedish [ __ ] viking you gotta
get over your phobia man
you gotta get over it
oh
oh i know it's macarons but it looks so
[ __ ] nasty let's move on to the next
one
oh god
[Music]
i agree and they're all the same
i want to die now what happened
life is not worth living
michael yeah give my channel to edgar
it's not worth it it's not worth living
on this planet
i'm scared he's not even wearing [ __ ]
gloves
he's not even wearing gloves by the end
of this video that man
will be me that man is my
hero what the [ __ ] this is a google maps
link
what the [ __ ] is this
we need to bomb that place right [ __ ]
now
calling calling ethan greg berry calling
mr president calling
mr president i have the coordinates 49
what [ __ ] country can contain this
evil
what [ __ ] place on this planet can
contain
that is hell that sword of cap
washington
[Music]
oh god it's mozzarella isn't it but god
damn do i hate it
food is something you don't stop ruining
food for me thank you very
[ __ ] much oh you were still with me
because this this is hard man i
i i understand that i'm not the oh all
right video
[Music]
earwax
oh no oh no who made this you're [ __ ]
[ __ ] weirdo what the [ __ ] why does it
look like popcorn
is that a baby in his ear
[Music]
why is there baby in there get it all
out
get it all out oh god
just clean your [ __ ] ears man
why would you do that to your face best
halloween costume ever
worst with the worst it's the worst oh
it's oh
it's flowers and it's supposed to be
beautiful but god damn
oh this is rubber bands
this one is weird
oh my god hello it's me in the morning
ladies
sorry
yeah that's me right after i don't know
we got one more one more to be amazed
one more
to have some [ __ ] balls on your chin
one more baby
come on come on oh this is weird toys it
can't be that bad
but not even barbie deserve this
[Music]
the earth is beautiful
the earth is a beautiful place
there is no such thing as irregular
holes
i believe in love
there is no such thing my dream is to
build a temple
in peru
[Music]
i'm crying all right hope you enjoyed
this video if you did
slam that like on so i get more likes
because i don't know i guess it helps
biggest channel on youtube i have no
[ __ ] clue how this site works
uh let me know though whatever all right
maybe leave a comment
maybe hit subscribe twice [ __ ] with the
system i don't know
but as always thank you so much for
watching and stay awesome bruce
[Music]
got a lot of
try not to last challenge collected like
gary the liking
is that leafy all right here you go
they ask you how you are you just have
to say that you're fine and you're not
really fine but you just can't